So Monday was my 41st birthday and this
helium inflated storm troopers showed up
at my door and I couldn't possibly pass
up the opportunity to use him as both a
prop and a metaphor for this week's
direct message.
One of the ideas which keeps popping up
in the discussions we're having around
here is that old political labels are
becoming more and more meaningless by
the day.
The terms progressive and liberal had
virtually nothing to do with each other
anymore.
And if you're a classical liberal,
you're certainly not a leftist.
Conservative and Republican don't have
much to do with each other today.
As trump,
a populist who doesn't focus on social
issues like gay marriage and legalizing
marijuana is now the leader of the gop
for these reasons as well as the real
time crumbling of our mainstream media.
The battle for freedom now is between
the authoritarians and the Libertarians.
That is the battle over the soul of
America and the West in general is now
about people who want the government to
have more control over your life versus
the people who want the government to
have less control over your life.
I think that by now you probably know
that I fall solidly in the camp of the
people who want the government to have
less control over how you live,
and that brings me to my friendly and
trustee storm trooper beside me in the
original 1977 star wars.
The storm troopers were the foot
soldiers for the Galactic Republic,
a massive evil military regime who
wanted to control every star system in
the galaxy.
This would qualify as authoritarian.
The empire and the storm troopers were
not keepers of the piece as the emperor
had promised,
but authoritarian rulers who wanted to
end this the expand their power,
hence they're building of the death star
to blow up any planet which didn't fall
in line with their desires.
Blowing up a planet is a pretty good way
to get people to do what you want.
A dare I talk about the prequels,
but trust me,
it works with this metaphor.
Two thousand to star wars episode to
attack of the clones takes place about
20 years before the original star wars
in this film,
the storm troopers at that time known as
the clone troopers,
were the good guys.
They allied with the Jetta in defense of
the Democratic Republic.
Eventually Chancellor Palpatine,
who had consolidated power himself and
secretly ordered the creation of the
clone army,
took control of the storm troopers and
the Senate and use democracy against
itself at the same time,
going from chancellor to emperor in 2015
is the force awakens,
which takes place about 20 years after
the original trilogy.
The storm troopers are again the bad
guys.
This time in the form of the soldiers
for the authoritarian first order,
which has risen from the ashes of the
Galactic Republic.
One of the heroes of the story,
Finn is a storm trooper gone rogue,
who suddenly realizes that he as an end
of individual,
can chart his own destiny.
He puts,
his collective is passed as a storm
trooper behind him and he becomes one of
the heroes of the story.
The point of all of this is that it
isn't this storm trooper,
you should fear it's the power which
commands him.
Any ideology can be used as a force for
good or for evil,
and that's why we should be reigning in
authoritarianism of any kind,
even when it's your sort of
authoritarianism in charge.
This whole metaphor took place in a
galaxy far,
far away,
but the lessons that it presents are
ones we can use right here on earth.
Joining me to discuss authoritarianism,
burst libertarianism is author,
professor and podcast or fattiest
Russell,
our friends with learn liberty if send
them our way and to loosely quote Obi
wan Kenobi.
This is the episode you've been looking
for.
We're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty today and joining me is an
adjunct professor at William at
University and author of a renegade
history of the United States.
That is Russell.
Welcome to the Rubin report.
Thanks for having me.
That he is Russell.
That is a name.
Sure is of a man who I feel knows what
he's saying.
You know what I mean?
Like there's some Gravitas to your name.
Do you feel that,
first of all,
my mother gets all the credit,
you know,
people sort of a compliment me on my
name all the time and I say,
Hey,
I had nothing to do with it.
I wish I could take credit for it,
but do you see that as the like just a
hideous and it's unfortunate because
then I have to be good.
Yeah.
I have to sort of say things that make
sense and it's a lot of pressure for me.
Yeah,
you just put on me.
Thanks.
I just put an extra dose.
If right now for an hour you're going to
have to make perfect sense because you
know about this.
This is the internet pipe.
Perfect sense coming up.
Video.
People are going to judge every word
that comes out of your mouth.
Yeah,
I've noticed that,
but I'm looking forward to this because
we're going to talk about postmodernism.
I think you have a slightly different
take than some of my previous guests.
You have an interesting history,
so let's just dive into it.
You grew up in a Marxists household in
Berkeley,
California.
I've given a lot of good buzzwords right
there.
In that first sentence,
what was that like?
You could also have said the sixties and
seventies when I was growing up.
Yeah,
that's a lot.
I'd be right there.
That's a lot.
Plus that name,
that Israel.
So we combine things here.
I'm kind of done.
I mean we can stop the interview now.
Yeah.
No.
My parents were members of a small
Trotskyist sect.
It was called the international
socialists and what they did was they
industrialized,
which meant that they left their
middleclass lives and went into heavy
industry and to organize the proletariat
for revolution.
So my mother became a clerical worker to
organize the secretaries for revolution
and my stepfather,
who had gone to Exeter Academy and the
University of Chicago,
he left his world to become a
steelworker and a truck driver.
And his mission was to convince the
workers to rise up and bring about a
communist revolution.
So that was unsuccessful and know what
caused them to do it.
Was it just generally what was happening
around then with the ward and it's hard
to.
It's hard to explain why people come to
particular ideologies,
but they chose Berkeley and the sixties,
they moved there and fell in with this
hardcore group and that's,
that was their lives.
And so that was my life when I was
growing up and we had meetings in our
house and the comrades were sitting down
downstairs and talking about stuff.
I had no idea what they're talking
about.
I learned later,
but you know,
it was heavy Marxist theory and which,
which a union shop should we infiltrate
and which factory should we organize.
And,
and then there were visitors to our
house,
you know,
there were black panthers.
We lived about three blocks from the
black panthers national headquarters,
which was actually in Berkeley and not
in Oakland.
Um,
and they were around and sort of hippies
were around and members of the IRA came
and gave speeches and stuff like that.
So,
and my mother,
one of the interesting things is that my
mother was the dominant figure in my,
in my family.
She was the heavy duty intellectual
actually.
And so the idea of women being weak or
victimized or unable to compete with men
has always been just a weird thing for
me.
Alien idea,
because she was always the dominant
force and I always looked up to her and
try to model myself after her.
So were you.
Once you became of age and started
thinking about these ideas,
did you immediately jive with these
ideas?
Did you have pushback or.
So I will say this.
My parents,
as I recall,
did not try to indoctrinate me directly,
but you can't help it,
right?
I mean,
if you're.
If you're raised in a church family,
you're gonna think that that's the truth
and correct and the way to be.
And that's what I said.
I mean,
my mother said that inspect.
You said this in one of her speeches
that when I was about 10 years old,
she said,
I want to grow up to be in the IAS.
That's what I want to be.
I'm going to be a socialist model.
How do I do that?
And that was kind of my mission and it
really means that it's.
When I went to college,
I didn't know what socialism even was,
and so that was my.
I said this,
I said I'm going to learn what socialism
is and then become a socialist and sort
of what I did for awhile.
Uh,
and,
but that,
that were off.
So you,
you write a lot and you talk about the
outsiders.
Really the rebels,
the people,
the drunks,
the fringes of society,
the people that were probably add a lot
of these meetings now you don't know.
No,
not the people.
that's.
No,
that's a misconception about.
Yeah,
my work.
So it's okay.
Please clean it up.
Yeah.
No,
no.
Um,
so know the people well,
okay.
Let me,
let me tell you how I got there for.
So I ended up going to Antioch College
in Ohio,
which is this ultra ultra left college
run by hippies and anarchist basically,
and,
and punk rockers.
And in fact we use,
that's evergreen state.
I was just gonna say mean.
We used to compete with evergreen for
being the most politically correct,
the most left wing college in the
country.
And we always thought,
oh,
they don't know what they're doing.
We are the true radical college.
That's hilarious.
I think we,
the champions,
and there's,
I have a lot of stories I could tell you
about the insanity at Antioch College,
which is kind of one of the reasons I
started to think twice about this.
Politics and culture.
And can you give me one example is just,
let's just dive into that one second
because that's this interesting.
Let me give you two.
One is just sort of tragic and
disgusting and the other more comical,
the tragic and disgusting one was the.
There were two kids at Antioch when I'm
in my third year who had,
um,
an antichristian art exhibit.
And so they had crosses on the wall and
they had a fire in a barrel in the
middle of the room.
And at one point they took one of the
crosses down and threw it in the barrel.
Right?
Everyone there understood this was an
antichristian statement.
Oh No,
this was racism.
This was the Ku Klux Klan.
Those kids got expelled.
Wow.
Because it was widely perceived to be an
act of,
you know,
racist violence,
and they had to leave the college and I
was the editor of the newspaper at the
time and I said,
this is kind of my turning point for me.
I said,
what are you talking about?
This is insane.
It really had this witch hunt feel on
campus and it felt I felt guilty and bad
for having to come to their defense
simply to explain.
That had nothing to do with race at all
and then.
And that there was that,
there was this hysteria that really
takes no prisoners.
I mean,
you have to be,
you have to eliminate the evil once you
identify it.
Why do you think that that ideology
breeds that hysteria?
Because we're seeing this literally
right now.
Yeah.
There's something that goes on in
college campuses.
Actually,
my mother said this to me when that
happened.
She said,
well,
you know what?
They need the devil.
They need to have a devil.
As soon as you step on campus,
you start reading about the history of
oppression and you know,
I think a lot of that's correct in many
ways.
Uh,
there's a lot of bad things that have
happened in this country and elsewhere.
And then you look around and you're an
affluent,
very privileged person in this world.
You're in the top one percent or more,
every college student basically is that,
especially at Antioch.
So there is no devil,
there is no,
there is no bull connor,
you know,
there,
there's no one like that around here.
So you have to find one.
And so what we did was we kind of
focused on that administrators,
the president and his evil
administrators.
We just inherently have to be eve.
We assumed they were evil and they were
out to get us.
And so we had to get them.
And so one day,
uh,
two kids broken when night two kids
broke into the president's office and
took a shit on his desk.
And that was our,
that was our statement.
That was,
that was telling him who is,
who works at many levels and what was,
what,
uh,
yeah.
So,
I mean those are just two of the most
comical,
uh,
you know,
are worst things that happened at
Antioch in that way.
It was also very liberating place.
I mean,
there was a lot of the hippies were good
in some ways.
I mean there was a lot of nudity and
smoking pot and lots of sexual freedom
which has gone now and college campuses
and I love that stuff,
but I hated this puritanical wing
culture and that's when I started to
move against it.
And then I went to Columbia for graduate
school and everybody there is a Marxist
or a socialist or maybe a new deal,
liberal,
but everybody's on the left.
Everybody.
And this was upper west side of
Manhattan as you know.
And,
and I,
I needed to be a socialist and so I
started to study as hard as I could to
be a socialist and be a socialist
historian,
be I became a Labor historian,
which is what you're supposed to do.
But I started noticing that all of these
people didn't care what clothes they
wore.
They had no idea what movies were
applying.
They never watched television.
They were completely oblivious to the
lives of real people.
And in particular,
we actually,
I'd say they were actually hostile to
the ways in which ordinary Americans
chose to spend their leisure time.
So popular culture was something that
was bad.
It was a false consciousness,
in fact,
right?
This is a,
this is an idea from the Frankfurt
school,
from Adorno.
He said this,
he said,
popular culture is simply the way the
capitalist class maintains control.
And so we must do away with it.
I said,
that's awful.
It's,
it's worse than off totalitarian.
There's many arguments for saying that a
lot of pop culture is nonsense.
It dribble.
And I mock it constantly.
Um,
but also people need an escape.
It's also part of human nature.
It's,
it's,
these are the things that rise up that
had some resonance with people.
I want to say it's better than an
escape.
So you know,
a lot of my work is about puritanism and
its long history and people aren't
really aware of how it carries through
to today.
So the,
that the heart of the pure of puritanism
is the puritan work ethic and a lot of
people get confused about this.
They think it's a working hard to get a
nice house or a big television or a nice
car.
It's not.
It's the idea that work in itself no
matter what you get for it is virtuous.
So you should work all the time no
matter what you get for it.
I'm so popular culture in this country
since it started in early 19th
centuries,
always been an a and not just an escape
from that.
It's been,
in a way a repudiation of that because
the puritans and their descendants,
the victorians in the 19th century said,
all these things are terrible.
At that time it was dime novels,
which were the first novels,
you know,
it was going to the nickelodeons,
it was gambling was going to the horse
races,
sports,
all that stuff.
They said,
we can't do that.
That's,
that's evil.
That's Satan's work.
We must avoid that.
We must work all the time and raise our
families and that's it.
So popular culture for me has
essentially been a repudiation of the
puritan work ethic.
It's always been this counter force
against that in our culture and there's
this constant fight between the two.
So you'll see,
like in politics,
politicians,
you won't find a president or a senator
until Donald trump actually who hasn't
criticised popular culture in some way.
Right?
Because they are.
They have to be the models of the sort
of puritanical repressive.
Good American guy.
Thanks a lot.
Hi.
No,
sorry.
no,
that's great.
So is there,
when you're discussing this,
it sounds like there's a religious
connotation there and when people hear
the word puritanical,
they think of a religious
connection,
but in and of itself,
there isn't really a religious
connection,
right?
There's,
there's the ideas of a religious
authority or something like that,
but it's not religious per se.
It's not necessarily religious.
Another argument I make,
and I think this might resonate with
you,
is that modern day progressivism and
left politics generally is secular
religion.
It's really secular Christianity.
So in particular,
I mean,
I think it's,
you see,
you see a lot of puritanism in left wing
politics and that's been true for a
long,
long time.
There's actually a couple of very good
books about um,
are showing that left wing intellectuals
for the last hundred years have been a
uniformly hostile to popular culture
that until very recently the sort of
hipster communists and Brooklyn talk
about pop culture until them
who all were the same glasses at the
same facial hair.
They pretend they do and I've had
arguments with them.
They picked hand that Lenin loved,
loved the movies.
No,
I mean Marx,
Lenin,
Trotsky,
all of them,
you name it and all the intellectuals
and the universities who are,
who are on the left have all like Adorno
have all hated pop culture and seeing it
as false consciousness.
Because,
and I said this once to professor at
Columbia,
very prestigious feminist gender studies
professor wants.
I said,
why?
Why do you,
why do you hate the fact that so many
women just like to go shopping or like
to go to the movies?
And she said,
because I think they have better things
to do with their time,
I mean,
right?
So that's judge.
So it's elitist,
it's judgmental,
it's at least authoritarian.
I think it might be totalitarian.
And this is my critique of the Frankfurt
school,
not postmodernism.
Different things by the way.
I do want to get very different things.
Um,
to me it's totalitarian because their
idea is that your ideas are wrong.
False.
That's their term.
They use that and they're leading you to
do things that are counter to your own
interests.
So we know what your own interests are
and we know how you should best arrive
at them to gain them.
So we're going to tell you what music to
listen to,
what movies to go see.
Probably no movies,
but what you should do with your life,
right time,
right?
It's,
it's actually totalitarian,
which is why that crew,
the people who followed the Frankfurt
school in the fifties and sixties,
the left wing movements that they became
very attracted to during the time.
Uh,
we're mallism with third world communism
because that's what Maoism looked like.
It was this idea that we must rid
ourselves of our bad ideas before the
revolution can happen.
It's,
it's fundamentally totalitarian.
It's about the total person.
Yeah.
Alright,
so let's back up.
Let's back up a couple of things.
I think you're going to be bouncing
around a lot here,
so I love this concept of what you said
that trump was the first one to reject
this because during the election I think
a lot of people noticed and I think what
people partly didn't like about Hillary
was the,
you know,
she's on stage with Katy Perry.
Then Madonna is doing a thing the day
before,
like just this absolute connection
between pop culture and politics that
started feeling gross.
It started feeling like the powers that
be between entertainment and politics
were so in bed together.
They all hated trump and I think that
then boosted his support.
Do you think that's a fair estimate and
do you think that was a calculated move
by him or was it just he had been pinned
into a corner because nobody,
none of those people would back in
except for a few of the deplorable
rejects.
Like Ted nugent and Scott,
I mean,
I guess I don't have the same critique
of that that you do.
I have no problem with what you said,
but it just.
I take a different line on it.
I mean to me Katy Perry and Madonna
being front people for Hillary is a
contradiction because hillary represents
second wave feminism,
which was read Betty for Dan,
if you don't agree with me,
I mean if you don't believe me,
was a rejection of the objectification
of women in all forms,
right?
So that any showing of skin,
any sexualization of women was bad and
need to be left behind free.
Dan said in her book the Feminine
Mystique that women should become
leaders of corporations,
leaders of government,
and that's it,
and she.
She has several chapters in that book
that are rejections of sex in particular
and also she attacks gay men for being
eternal boys who were obsessed with sex
and for seducing housewives into being
obsessed with sex.
This was free dance whole thing.
She thought that women were themselves
too interested in sex and what they
should be interested in was work
puritanism.
Here you are,
right?
And so Hillary Clinton is the apotheosis
of that,
isn't she?
Right.
Because she wears the business suits.
She is ultra rational,
she is ultra disciplined.
She has her husband get sex elsewhere.
If he does,
he does the bad stuff.
Uh,
so she is this,
she's the perfect second wave feminists.
So Katy Perry showing her boobs on stage
and you know,
Madonna having done the same thing
before.
That's a rejection.
That's a contradiction of a second wave
feminism.
So someone's not understanding something
here.
I think Hillary does use them but
probably isn't really a big fan of what
they're doing.
Right.
So you know,
there there's something,
there's a contradiction that it needs to
be resolved.
Do you think though that,
that contradiction,
like I think people see that even even
if they don't understand the full
history of it or the full philosophical
underpinnings,
I think people kind of see that and I
think that possibly did drive more
people to trump.
Do you think that makes sense?
Um,
I don't know.
I mean,
if it was a rejection of all of it,
it was just a rejection of just this,
this monstrosity.
I.
Oh yeah.
I think that a lot of people,
again,
I don't know,
and people.
I hate the way that people sort of
presumed to know what trump voters
thought.
You better know everything otherwise,
what the hell are we doing?
My name is Thaddeus.
I better know they,
you know,
but I do think it's reasonable to assume
how's that,
um,
that a lot of them were rejecting or
reacting to this repressive puritanism
in Clinton and politics generally that
and which is not just cultural.
It's not just about sex,
it's that you're not allowed to say all
kinds of things if you're an American
politics.
Right.
It's is very restricted discourse that's
allowed in American politics.
I'm sure that was a lot of what went on.
In fact,
I did hear a lot of people say that
trump says what he thinks.
Yeah.
Just that was very attractive to a lot
of people and that was attractive to me.
I didn't like most of what he said,
but I did like that he was breaking down
the walls.
Right.
And Bernie to some extent was doing that
too,
you know,
and so I thought that was very good even
though I didn't like either one of them
in terms of their content,
but I did like that they were simply
challenging the walls.
Do you think that right there is sort of
what the next evolution of politics is
going to be?
Because I've been saying for awhile now,
I feel like the chess board has just
been thrown up.
We've got fertile ground now.
We don't know what's going to grow with
it.
I think there's,
you know,
the traditional labels of left,
right are becoming meaningless.
What really is a Republican in the age
of trump,
which is sort of a different thing than
conservatism,
all of that.
Do you think that the next wave of
politics is really going to be about the
realignment?
I hope this stuff.
I hope so.
Um,
I do.
I know,
I know you've been talking about this a
lot on your show.
You know,
this,
this split between authoritarianism and
whatever you want to call it,
libertarianism,
small l broadly conceived,
right?
That's what I hope.
Do we need a better word for that?
Because I think because I do believe
that's what it is.
That is authoritarianism verse
libertarianism.
But I think when you say libertarianism,
people think of it as some sort of
offshoot strange political parties
there.
Is there a better phrase than mean?
So for instance,
I have many differences with
libertarian,
so people often lumped me in with them
and,
but ask a libertarian,
I mean that's like a hardcore
libertarian about fatty as Russell
that's like,
oh,
he's not a libertarian.
I have many differences with them.
Although in some things I very much
agree,
but they're,
they,
they're,
um,
hostility to or opposition to the state
and state power.
Uh,
I'm completely with them on that.
I think markets are very responsive to
consumers needs and I think they advance
humanity in many,
many ways.
I don't think they're perfect.
I'm think capitalism is perfect and
that's one of their problems.
But anyway,
I do think that general idea,
that basic idea that we should be free
from control by others,
those in authority in particular,
those with state power,
which is the monopoly on violence,
right,
um,
is a good thing.
So I,
I,
I love that about them and I love that
about this sort of new formation I see
happening and you're a part of that and
some of your guests are part of that
versus Democrats and Republicans who do
wants to control us.
Liberals and conservatives who do want
to control us in various ways.
I would like to see a new realignment
around that.
I would like to see us talk about
politics in those terms because of right
and left.
I think you're right.
No longer make make much sense unless
you're very specific about what you mean
by them.
So we've talked a little bit more about
the left so far and you know,
my feelings.
I'm trying as as a liberal,
I'm trying to clean up
what the left is and I,
at this point,
I don't think that being a liberal and
being on the left or even compatible,
unfortunately.
But let's talk about the right a little
bit,
right?
What is right?
Authoritarianism right now,
right wing authoritarianism is sort of
what we know.
I mean it's using the state to control
people's personal lives,
so they don't want women to choose to be
able to choose abortions.
They don't want us to actually.
They're very concerned about popular
culture,
so they want to control what we watch
and listen to know they don't like a lot
of Hollywood.
They don't like a lot of what happens in
the music industry.
They've held marches and protests and
called for laws to censor those things
and they also want to control what
happens in the rest of the world in
various ways.
They want to send out the United States
Army to control how people think and
behave.
Now,
the thing is that lately,
and I think again,
this is where,
where you've been going a lot with your
show,
is that there's been a convergence
between the conservatives,
the Republicans,
and the Liberals,
the Democrats on many of these
questions.
So for instance,
hip hop,
here we go.
Popular Culture,
if you look at the reaction to hip hop
over the last 20 years,
the negative reactions to the calls to
censor it,
it was tipper Gore,
it was a lot of feminists and it was
Christian conservatives joining
together.
Al Sharpton was another one who held
marches against hip hop,
you know,
calling for music companies to shut down
these,
these artists and center the lyrics.
So there's a lot of convergence around
this.
Authoritarianism.
Yeah.
So where does trump fit into that?
Because he doesn't care about video game
violence or words that are in rap songs
or even abortion,
I don't think he particularly cares
about.
Certainly not about gay marriage.
So those things that are thought of as
right,
authoritarianism,
all these people that are marching with
Hashtag resist or are they sort of
missing the boat on who they should be
attacking?
Right.
It would have been a great thing if he
had had more than two or three people in
the world who agreed with him.
We're in Washington DC on these things,
right?
So unfortunately he brought just as tiny
little crew to Washington and had to
fill all these posts,
you know,
all these jobs and the only people
available.
Unfortunately we're Christian
conservatives and generals.
Right.
And so what we have is,
and Mike Pence,
right?
So Mike Pence comes from the Christian
conservatives conservative wing and
they've gotten their,
you know,
their hold on him sessions.
I think there's another one,
right?
The who actually thinks that marijuana
is dangerous to people.
I mean,
it's,
it's phenomenal.
The guy is an absolute neanderthal and
this stuff,
I do think that he's not going to be
successful because I think that that war
has been won by us,
you know?
But,
um,
but it's,
it's,
it's unfortunate that trump,
I think he feels beholden to them.
He can't hold any power without the
Christian conservative base.
And so he's not being really forceful in
his championing of popular culture,
which he comes right out of it.
Right.
You know,
I mean,
look at who he is,
he's the,
he's the zenith of it.
Wife
is a model and you know,
all the rest of it.
I mean,
that's.
So,
yeah.
So trump,
and that's one of the reasons I think
that he makes people crazy.
In fact,
I actually think that's the main reason
he makes both sides.
Liberals and conservatives absolutely
lose their stuff,
which is that p is that he breaks those
rules.
Cultural rules.
So if you look at,
if you look at puritanism,
right,
what I was talking about,
the work ethic,
what does Donald Trump do?
He got a bunch of money from his dad and
he kind of lives large on his private
jets.
Everything is in,
you know,
everything is covered in gold and what,
who does that other than Donald Trump
rappers,
you think about this,
right?
He does a lot of the stuff that,
you know,
the bad black people have done.
They celebrate their bodies and they
don't care about,
you know,
conventional rules and norms and
bourgeois morality and all that stuff.
And um,
you know,
he's,
he's not shy about talking about sex.
That's also something you can't do.
That's an absolute taboo.
He breaks all those cultural rules.
I actually think that's why they go
crazy about Donald Trump in a bad way
because basically they don't know how to
fight it because they are constrained by
sort of other rules.
Right?
It's so fundamental to who they are and
what their world is.
When we walk around in America,
generally speaking,
we don't talk about sex.
We just don't.
It's the silence that we impose on
ourselves.
We all are proud of when we work hard,
even if we don't make a nickel for it.
Right.
It is so central to who we are.
We've internalized it.
It's not like people walk around saying,
Oh,
I'm a puritan,
and here's what the weirdest thing.
It's just.
It's completely deeply embedded inside
of us.
Since the puritans got here and that's
what trump just seems to not seem to be
oblivious to.
Sort of that fundamental American
culture and I would say it's really a
middle class culture,
so working class people of all colors
have generally speaking and immigrants
to have kind of avoided that stuff.
They haven't internalized it,
of course,
because they're sort of outside of the
realm of power and they're outside of
citizenship.
Right.
And so for whatever reason,
I don't know why trump is much more like
them,
even though he's always been a rich kid.
He sort of adopted that kind of working
class indifference to Bush morality and
it people can't stand that.
What does that tell you about politics?
Sort of between the ideas and just the
cult of personality?
Yeah.
Someone that you obviously care about,
ideas,
you have a command of the ideas.
You were born out of certain ideas that
you later challenge and sort of
incorporated into what you do now,
but basically everything you said is
this is just cultive personality of what
he's doing.
There's a fundamental,
very depressing problem that I'm sort of
just coming to grips with or coming to
terms with now in my own life,
which is that,
and that's sort of known this all along,
but it's really hitting me hard,
is that even with the Internet,
even though I think people are better
informed now than ever before,
because of that,
the vast,
vast,
vast majority of Americans don't know
anything about politics.
So that's just even spending time on
twitter.
This is a problem no matter what your
politics are as a public political
person or a public intellectual,
you know,
people don't even like that word.
Right?
And it,
all it means is you're a lover of ideas
that you're curious about big ideas and
you talk about ideas.
That's it.
You know,
people don't even like it when you use
that smug son of.
I know I'd smug as the word had been
called recently more than once.
It's a,
it's a problem.
I mean,
for what we do,
right.
It's,
you know,
so that's why we have those of us in
this little world talk to each other
most of the time.
Yeah,
right,
because most Americans have never heard
of Syria,
much less know anything about it.
You know,
most Americans.
I mean,
look at the polls.
It's just most Americans I think don't
know who the vice president is.
It's something like that.
I mean they can't identify Washington dc
on a map,
you know,
huge portions of the American public
don't know anything.
Is,
is that just a function of our success
that we are perhaps the most successful
nation in the history of the world?
Uh,
we have done tremendous amounts of good.
We've done plenty of bad at the same
time.
We brought in more people from every
walk of life.
All of these things.
We've created this system that basically
still is pretty great at what you get
out of that after the sausage is you get
sort of dumb down thing because people
have video games and have leisure and
sports and all of those things.
Yeah.
So I think those are good things.
I mean,
I think it's pretty great and that
doesn't mean there aren't problems and I
wish more people cared about ideas and
all that,
but that it's just the function of
success is some of this.
Yeah,
you don't need to care about stuff.
You don't need to think,
you don't need to read Co.
You can start all you want about what he
thinks,
but you don't need to read them because
no one does.
So there's no one ever checks You on it.
Right?
Um,
but that,
so yeah,
I mean,
I,
it's like I often say to people like you
and me,
it's like,
are we sure we want to be doing this
when we have a better time in a better
life?
If we were just following sports
instead.
I love sports.
It's funny,
I had jason whitlock from fox sports one
on a couple of weeks ago and he was so
clearly passionate noses,
thoughts and all that stuff about
politics and the wider world.
And then when he left I was like,
man,
that guy gets to talk about sports or
anything.
I was like,
that would be pretty great if I was an
nba analysts,
but we do love this.
That's the,
that's the,
I don't know.
I mean,
aren't we can flip flop.
I love it.
Well you do,
but you're also fortunate by it.
Yeah,
it's exhausting.
when,
when articles and publications call me
an outright extremist or you know,
and then I have to go,
well now do I want to spend my day
fighting this or just letting it be or.
But it all,
it's fighting.
That's what it is.
Right.
And so half the time I love the fight
and half the time I hate it.
I don't know what else to say.
I mean,
I don't know what else I could do.
I would love to be like a boxing coach
instead,
but I don't think I can.
And um,
I'd like to be in the nba,
right?
Probably not.
So you know,
you know,
jews used to dominate basketball.
I know in this country.
Oh,
you do know this.
I know,
I know.
There were a lot of jews in the early
days of the mba.
Now it's dominated.
It's too late for dominated 40 with a
badge,
so you could bring that back.
You know.
Now that I think there are no jews and
the mta.
You can be the first and not one jew.
That's pretty sad.
I've heard that Jordan farmar is half
jewish.
That's about it.
They got them out.
They found out.
I think they actually sent it to Israel,
but total sidebar,
but wait,
I want to focus a little more on that,
on that right authority thing because it
isn't the part of the authoritarian
stuff that I focus on a lot,
so I do want to spend a little more
time.
They a part of it doesn't make sense to
me.
Like it Seems to me that on something
like gay marriage,
if the right that supposedly believes in
states rights and in the individual and
in local limited government,
all of those things,
they had such an easy opportunity to do
the right thing with gay marriage.
Now,
of course it got screwed up because of
the christian conservatives,
but even right now with marijuana,
as you're talking about with jeff
sessions,
it's like you guys are the ones that are
supposed to care about limited
government and not having the government
tell people what they can do in their
own home.
Why are they unable to take a principled
position here?
Um,
it.
Well,
I don't know about being.
Okay.
Well,
I think for me,
and did I lead too much?
No,
no,
no.
I think that conservative or republican
authoritarianism is different in a very
important way and it's the reason that I
like you focus much more on left
authoritarianism,
which is that they are dumber.
No,
Really,
they are less effective at getting
authoritarian politics out there and
distributed and bought into the
sessions.
This is what I was saying about
sessions,
right?
Good lUck buddy.
Like convincing America to roll back
legalization of pot.
It ain't gonna happen,
right?
Um,
you're certainly not going to convince
anyone of this stuff.
I mean,
no one,
no one believes other than jeff
sessions.
Really.
That pot is harmful to you in the way
that he's talking about.
Um,
but then yeah,
what does that say that,
that even president obama was still
having the feds shut down the local
things like here in college.
That is my point.
That is exactly what I'm saying here.
So the sessions won't be able to do it.
Obama could because everybody loved
obama because obama played by all the
rules because he was the perfect
american man and he was black and so he,
he kInd of fixed our are bad history for
us too.
He made us feel better.
He was our salvation.
He was,
he was perfect.
He was almost a jesus fIgure.
And that's real and I mean that people
really did treat him that way.
And I don't think that's an exaggeration
if you look at it right.
And so he could send in the feds to shut
down marijuana dispensaries and no one
batted an eye certainly on the left.
But why did he.
Oh,
why did.
Yeah,
I see what you're saying on the one that
he can get away with it.
But why do you think he did?
If most likely he doesn't really care
about
marIjuana laws,
do you think?
I don't know.
I,
I would say that he,
like,
like people in the progressive left and
I include liberals in this are
interested primarily in social control,
so they need.
And that's not,
it doesn't,
that's not saying that they're evil,
that's just who they are.
They like a well ordered society,
so I don't know,
but I would suspect and look at obama,
he's like the paragon of discipline,
right?
He is actually the perfect pure attend
at least as far as we know.
Right.
Um,
I would say that part of it that he
didn't like the fact that people were
violating federal law and I think
getting high,
I think he now sees as,
as disruptive,
right?
It's not a good thing.
Um,
so look at his sermons.
Here you go.
Sermons or lectures or speeches,
whatever you want to call them.
Interesting choice against black
culture,
which people sort of don't pay attention
to,
but he gave many.
every time the guy got in front of a
black audience,
he would start lecturing them about
watching too much espn and about how
they needed to pull up their pants and
how much,
how they needed to work harder and raise
their children.
Right.
And stop eating.
Popeye's chicken,
google it.
I mean he went and michelle did the same
thing,
this really stern admonitions of,
of black culture.
So I think that's all of the piece.
I think that's probably plays into why
he did go after the dispensary's.
Yeah,
got it.
There's a lot there.
So where we started before we went on
this 20 minutes a roundabout was I was
mentioning the,
you know,
the outcasts,
sort of the,
the drunks and all those people.
And then I said it was sorta like some
of the people that were in your house
growing up and you were making a
distinction that those are not the same
thing.
So let's,
let's go back to that.
That was good.
I had it there.
I knew we were going to get.
That was very good.
Um,
yeah.
So
the communists in my house growing up
were puritanical because as I said
earlier,
you know,
communists and socialists have always
been puritanical.
Again,
this is lots of literature has been
written on this.
This is not just me talking.
I'm lennon and marks were po,
sorry,
lenin and trotsky were opposed to
homosexuality because homosexuality was
sort of being bad in itself,
but because it was decadent,
so decadence was the problem for
communists throughout the 20th century.
They thought like adorno did later,
that it was this thing that was leading
the working class,
the decadence,
popular culture,
consumerism was leading the working
class astray with the working class
should be doing instead was organizing
themselves for revolution.
Now here's what they understood,
and this is why it's all logical.
Uh,
they understood that when you control or
manage a whole society,
which is what they wanted everyone to
do,
that requires tremendous discipline.
You can't be going to the movies if
you're going to be managing the economy.
Right?
And so that's what they said.
And I mean this was the,
this was their argument.
We need to instill this perfect
proletarian discipline.
It wasn't the phrase in the soviet union
and elsewhere,
and so my parents comrades came out of
that tradition.
They were trotskyists,
you know,
they came out of that and they
understood that,
so they may have watched some television
but they didn't.
they thought at best it was just an
escape.
right.
And what we really need to be doing is
studying gdp figures,
right?
And so,
so that we can manage the economy.
Everyone should be doIng that.
Everyone should be an engineer and
everyone should be ready to have
meetings all day long and all night long
to organize our society.
So it's so interesting because I don't
as you're saying that,
I was thinking that recently.
I've been saying this thing about how
comedy I think is dying right now too,
that there are in comics willing to
cross the line.
We've got bill maher apologizing for a
word even though no one in their right
mind thinks he's racist.
we've seen so many leftist progressive
comedians just making the same trump
jokes over again and not really pushing
the limits of what comedy is.
But with what you're saying,
it really does make sense why they
almost can't be funny.
This is what I've been saying,
that these progressives who are shutting
down pop culture in these ways are true
to their heritage.
This is what progressives,
I mean the progressives,
the original ones that the early 20th
century.
did they shut down the nickelodeons they
did they in every city in the country.
ProgressIve's launch these campaigns.
Can you just tell people what
nickelodeon's are?
Because a lot of people.
My younger audience is going to think
you mean with the green.
But that's not what you mean.
Yeah.
The nickelodeon network is named after
the cinemas in which started in the
lower east side of New York,
but grew and spread all over the
country,
which were a five cent cinemas.
You could go and put a nickel in and you
could watch a movie.
Yeah.
So I'm sure they would probably want to
go after the green room at some point
too,
because there's got to be some racial
connotation to that.
So the progressIve is in all the big
cities.
Shut down those nickelodeon's because
the working class was watching
burlesque,
you know,
or you know,
just or things that weren't about work
and you know,
discipline and war.
Um,
and so yeah,
it's,
they're being true to their heritage.
Yeah.
We should have culture that is
completely austere,
right.
And not fun or funny in those ways.
That's why the is so unfunny right?
Think about it.
I mean,
they're so earnest.
They're so earnest that they can't make
a joke.
Well,
that's the thIng.
They've been birth pepe and tech and
Pakistan and all.
They birthed it because it's these
people online that have Just had it with
the political correctness.
So noW they're sending out frogs with
swastika is just to get a reaction out
of people and people that think it's
hate speech.
I had horses,
I had gavin mcinnes on my show and you
know,
it became very clear to me about five
minutes in this is what's happening.
He's hilarious.
much oF what he says is either racist or
pretty damn close.
And the content of what he's saying,
I have a lot of trouble with.
I don't know how serious he is about it,
but it's,
it's clearly right wing in,
in pretty bad ways according to my
politics.
But he's really,
really funny.
He has the freedom to do that.
Comedy requires freedom.
Jim goad is another one.
You know,
he,
he just approached me.
He wants to be on my podcast and he.
But he and I started looking at his
writing.
Much of what he says is probably racist.
Probably sexist,
probably homophobic,
but he's hilarious.
He's very,
very funny.
So what do you do?
What I want to ask you that,
what do you do with that?
You personally,
what do you do with that when you're
sitting across from someone like that?
Right.
I don't know.
I laugh and I'm troubled and I feel like
if they are not.
However I feel like if they,
like with gavin mcinnes,
he has no real power,
right?
I mean,
no one's gonna listen to him and write
some policy based on this.
Um,
you know,
you could say he contributes to the
trump phenomenon,
but what's the trump phenomenon?
I mean,
there is no trump phenomenon anymore.
The generals have taken over basically,
you know,
um,
yeah,
once they attach themselves to any
movement that might seize state power,
oh then give me an ak 47,
but they,
these guys are so marginalized.
People talk about being marginalized,
the marginalized or those guys and what
they represent.
It's so interesting you say that because
that's the other reason that I focus on
the left is not just because I come from
it,
but also because I see that's where all
the power is seated the conversation and
see seated their hollywood is all those
things.
So when they get,
you know,
the,
the three white supremacists to show up
at a meeting somewhere and then of
course the media blows it out of
proportion as if there's nazis re
rampaging through the streets.
It's like you just need that,
need,
that belief.
Do you think that's a fair?
Oh,
absolutely.
Oh yeah.
No,
no.
Yeah,
I mean,
so they control most of the media.
It's just true.
Okay.
liberals,
liberals mostly.
Not really socialists,
but liberals controlled the media for
the most part other than fox news and
fox.
That's.
Well,
by the way,
if you've ever been in the fox news
green room,
you'll know that there's a lot of
liberals who even worked there,
the people behind the scenes,
there's tons.
I knew gay people that work there and
all sorts of New York city,
upper west side.
Exactly.
Um,
and they control academia and they
control what's now being called the deep
state,
whatever,
you know,
if that's whatever.
But you know,
in terms of the civil servants who work
in Washington dc and working all the
state capitals,
it's over.
We know this is overwhelmingly liberal.
So yeah,
this is why I get upset because they
control the world that I operate in.
They determine my fate in many ways.
So I know that just because of the
things that we talk about here every
week,
when you say the word liberal,
that a certain amount of my audience is
going to go,
wait a minute,
does he mean classical liberal or does
he mean progressive or leftist or
something?
You,
it's obvious to me you're making that
distinction,
but the word liberal has now been so
muddied that in some ways it's not even
worth the progressives who,
who,
uh,
shut down the nickelodeons and the turn
of the 20th century.
They're the ones who changed the meaning
of the word.
They seized it sort of after world war
one and said,
oh no,
we're liberals.
And people are like,
what are you talking about?
You're not liberals.
You want the state to control much of
the economy and,
and much of our lives.
And um,
but they,
they,
they started to use that word and it
stuck.
And so once the,
once the new deal happens in the 19
thirties,
franklin roosevelt becomes another jesus
fIgure and he calls himself a liberal
and they people call his movement
liberal then that was it.
That was the moment,
that turning point.
No,
this is all,
of course,
a repudiation of classical liberalism,
which is about the individual,
you know,
having some autonomy or at least freedom
from the state and its power.
Do you think that people like us can win
that word back?
That's what I've been thinking about
lately,
like I like making this argument for
liberalism versus the left.
I just don't think it's a liberal
movement anymore and I know that I
brought a lot of people to it and have
many allies that are doing similar work
that you included.
Um,
but do you think it's possible,
like the word liberal is now so tainted
that in the,
in the broader sense,
maybe we can build something around that
word.
Not to say the ideas can't be used in
another way.
Yeah.
So I'm not sure I want to.
So I'm not a classical liberal and I
don't love classical liberalism.
I like some of it,
but the,
the puritan notion of the repressed
individual who never talks about sex and
don't only have sex to procreate and he
works all the time.
That's actually at the center of
classical liberalism.
So if you read john locke and you read
the founding fathers,
this is what they say.
We must regulate ourselves so that the
state doesn't have to.
So it's a,
it's a cultural puritanism.
It's good that they don't want the state
regulating us in those ways,
so I liked that.
I like the bill of rights,
but they say for that to happen,
for that to be possible,
we must constantly police ourselves so
the cop becomes internal.
The police,
the policeman is inside of us,
so I don't love that.
yeah,
yeah.
that's interesting because I've never
thought of it in that I know exactly
what you're talking about,
but to me that was more of just a sign
of the times then versus now because
aren't we all policing ourselves in our
own way?
I mean every day you get up and you
don't do everything that every whim that
you want to do and every crazy urge that
you want to do.
So we're all sort of doIng that just by
living,
right?
Oh yeah,
sure.
It's not.
I mean it's not.
It wasn't a sign of the times that they
made this argument.
I mean lock and the founding fathers,
the whole first chapter of my book
renegade histories on this.
I mean if you think about it's
consistent,
right?
They wanted the people,
or at least some of the people,
many of the people to control the
country,
take it away from the king and run it
themselves,
and they understood this thing that the,
that the leninist understood a century
later,
which is that,
oh,
to do that,
jesus,
we've got to like learn a bunch of stuff
and we've got to stop,
you know,
going to the cockfights and stopped
smoking cigars.
No,
really stopped drinking most of all.
And because we got to work to do,
we've got to run this country.
Democracy I say is puritanical for that
reason.
So it's interesting because as you know,
you say you work with learn liberty,
their classical liberal organization.
They sent you to me.
I just want to make up nobody.
I want to make a point of sayIng that's
why it's a beautiful thing that we're
doing with them because you just said I
am not a classical liberal,
were where do you.
If you had to give yourself a label,
I kNow you don't want to get hung up on
that kind of stuff,
But I sense A lot of classical liberal
stuff from you.
I send some libertarian stuff from you.
I sent some utility of the state from
you.
What the hell is that?
I don't know.
Let's make up a new word.
I mean,
I don't know.
I,
I am.
I have sort of,
um,
culturally I guess I'm anarchistic.
I suppose I am.
I'm anti authority.
It doesn't mean I want to demolish
authority and remove authority.
In fact,
I like that there are some people in
this world who want to take charge
because I don't want to do that work.
Right?
I don't want to do that work.
It's weird,
right?
That there are some people who just want
to manage everything and like take
control and take care of everything.
I don't want to determine who picks up
your garbage on monday morning.
I mean,
That's fine.
I'm glad you want to do that.
I'd rather play video games or whatever
it is.
Right?
And so I don't know what that is.
I mean it's,
um,
that's why I like a lot of
libertarianism,
you know,
obviously because they want the state
out of our lives.
But a lot of libertarians have this
classical idea of the self regulating
individual.
They're right in the middle of it.
And so I don't like that at all because
they're kind of not fun either.
They were actually.
A lot of libertarians remind me of the
socialists that I grew up with.
They're very stodgy and very kind of
uptight and controlled and not
interested in the real world and the
pleasures and the real world.
All the pleasure they get is from
reading books,
whIch I understand,
but there's more to life than that.
You know,
this past week was,
or about a week ago is vidcon,
which is where all these youtubers get
together.
I didn't go,
but a lot of the people that are sort of
in my youtube circles,
most of them are younger than me were
there.
And it seemed like what I could gather
was they were the fun group that there's
these people on the left that are
screaming about the third wave feminism
and all this stuff,
and then they're at a youtube
conference.
It's not a lot of many people on the
traditional right,
but that this new group,
whatever this thing is of these sorta
half liberal libertarian mix,
whatever,
that they're the fun group and that's
what's attracting people.
I think that was probably a lot of what
was in the middle of gamer gate,
which was that there's these kids
playing video games who like looking at
women with big boobs and happy and
enjoying it.
Right.
And that was about it.
I think for most of them I would
imagine.
Right.
They like shooting people,
right?
Virtually,
you know,
and watching the heads explode,
which you're not allowed to do.
By the way,
that's another form of oppression that
the puritans and the victorians
instituted.
We can't fight each other in the
streets.
That's an archaic and disorderly.
We have to let the state do all the
killing for us.
Right?
We get the monopoly on violence,
the state does,
so you can't do that anymore.
So lIke boxing was shunned for a long
time.
All these things,
you know.
And so I think,
I think video games represent sort of a,
a return of the repressed to use freud's
term in that way because these kids are
doing stuff you're not allowed to do and
through these video games which is kill
and have sex or at least some kind of
sex,
sexual in that way.
And it's fun.
NoW we know that this didn't cause them
to go out and shoot people.
We know that it didn't cause them to go
out and rape people.
We know this from many,
many,
many studies with grace.
Every study,
every study,
okay.
So we just know that.
Um,
and so they were having fun doing this
stuff that you're not allowed to do or
even express.
You're not even allowed to express those
desires in this culture.
Right?
And then all of a sudden you have these
people coming in and swooping in and
telling them that not only what they're
doing,
just their thoughts,
their feelings are bad.
But that it's going to cause another
sandy hook and another mass rape
somewhere and that it's,
it's the cause of the subjugation of
women will.
It doesn't make sense to these kids.
And I'm,
I imagine,
and it's like we were just having fun in
our mom's basement.
We,
by the way,
we have zero institutional power in this
country.
Nothing,
nothing.
And you're telling us suddenly we're the
most powerful people in the world.
Now,
by the way,
I'm speaking for them now.
Here's what's so amazing to me.
It's like you've got a game or get hat
for where you are.
Here's what's so amazing to me.
It's like why are feminists or went or
any.
Why is everyone so concerned about what
those people think?
Like that's what it becomes important in
a lot of feminist discourse is what we
think.
What men think.
Well,
that all that does is sort of reinscribe
the patriarchy,
right?
What we think what we do is what's
important but men do and think is what's
important.
Well,
how about just saY I'm going to do what
I want to do and many feminists,
by the way have done this.
There's a,
there's a different strain of feminism
that I love which has been called sex
positive feminism or independent
feminism.
Right.
So that's sort of more the christina
hoff summers.
I know she doesn't focus that much on
sex,
but she but more just like let them do
their thing
maybe.
Yeah.
So I had a guest on my show,
her name is anna aerosmith,
she's a,
she was a feminist in and she hated
pornography.
She thought it degraded Women and then
she was walking down the street in soho
in london,
which is the red light district
basically in london thinking and
watching all these shops full of these,
you know,
video video's sex oliver.
And she was turned on by it and she
thought,
oh wait a minute,
I'm turned on by this,
but I don't like that.
So you know what I'm gonna do,
I'm going to make my own porn.
And so she started making your own
parents.
She became the biggest female
pornography in the world.
And did it on her own terms and it's all
hardcore.
There's nothing.
She doesn't hold any held anything back.
She just makes it nicer looking and the
men are better looking,
et cetera.
And that's it.
To me,
that's feminism.
Do it on your own,
make your own world right instead of
worrying constantly about what I want
and what I think.
Yeah.
How unhealthy do you think just having
to talk about politics all the time is.
I don't mean what we're doing right
here,
right?
So I don't mean for the people that have
these conversations about ideas in that,
but I mean for the average person that
all day long now because of social media
is harping about every little decision
that happens in the government and that
I,
it's strikes me as it's becoming,
it's starting to like really rocked
people's minds or something like,
I would argue that a good government is
one that's small enough that you
wouldn't have to talk about it all the
time.
Now this,
there's probably good counter arguments
to that,
but the idea that people are all day
worried about this seems like a real
problem.
Well,
so when you say people,
you know,
I mean,
how many people are we talking about?
Again?
I think it's right.
It's hard to gauge is the.
I think it's a lot of people to each
other,
right?
I think it's a pretty small world that
we inhabit or that we observe.
Right?
I think the,
I think most.
Well what is it?
Twenty five percent of americans are on
twitter.
Okay.
So that's a quarter.
That's a pretty big chunk.
But of those,
how many just read what katy perry's
feed,
right?
I mean I think that those who do
politics
bar bizarrely political though because
of doing stuff with hillary,
so.
Okay.
Yeah.
But let's say,
you know what's called political
twitter,
I don't know,
but how many people are there?
Right?
And how many people there are just,
you know,
just check in on the democratic party's
latest,
you know,
announcements,
right?
I think it's a pretty small world.
I'm not too worried about the population
in general.
Um,
but I do think that the world that you
and I have chosen to live in is pretty
uncomfortable.
And I'd say since the election in
particular,
it's nearly intolerable,
so I used to be a twitter addict and
then since the election it's actually
been really hard.
It's not been fun to go on twitter.
It really almost never is funded.
Almost always makes me sad or angry.
And so I watch it less,
you know,
and I don't know,
I think that may be the next phase we're
going to go through the twitter will
become something else or there will be
alternatives to it and you know,
it's just people talking.
The thing is to just keep going and not
a,
no,
it's hard,
but to not let the eggs with the five
followers get to you,
they get to me,
but we just have to keep going if we
want to do this.
Um,
what about the amount of time that we're
spending on this?
That I think that's really what I meant.
They're not just,
not just the griping but the amount of
time people are worried about these
things.
LIke the broader people.
Yeah.
I mean,
well,
the thing that I don't like is there,
the policing that goes on,
it's a constant policing,
right?
You said this and you shouldn't say
that.
You shouldn't think this,
you shouldn't feel this.
You need to check yourself.
You need to watch yourself.
It's all,
it's a totalitarian language.
Um,
which again,
by the way it comes out of the frankfurt
school.
It does,
which their argument was that language
is this tool of the oppressor against
the oppressed.
And so we need to,
we need to recapture the language and
make it our own to bring about
revolution.
That was the frankfurt school.
Um,
it's,
it's a totalitarian impulse.
It's a totalitarian politics.
It's no fun to be around.
And I think that's the thing.
People are just,
they're repudiating it sort of tacitly
in that they are there watching their
video.
They're,
they're playing video games instead
they're watching television instead.
They're not engaging in this discourse.
You and I are masochists because we do
It.
Most people are not masochists in that
way.
So that's,
to me the cause for hope.
Yeah.
It's so funny because I enjoy 90 percent
of this.
There is that 10 percent of just,
you know,
when people are malicious lead
misquoting me or writing things that are
blatantly not true,
the rest of the interaction,
I can basically deal with it.
I do love the battle of ideas,
but believe me,
I hear you.
There's,
there's like an unspoken thing that we
can do here that I can't quite quantify
in words.
So curious.
So all this being said,
you have an interesting mix,
you know,
a mixed match of politics and culture
and all that stuff.
Is there anyone in politics right now
that,
that you like,
that you go,
oh,
this guy kinda gets it.
No.
Electoral politics.
Yeah.
just anyone right now.
Who in the public space in general,
like is there like a couple?
Is there anyone
in electoral politics?
There's no one.
I mean,
in fact,
I thought trump was interesting in these
ways that he was at least raising these
questions for the first time.
I mean,
I can't stand most of what he's for in
terms of policy,
but he was raising these questions for
the first time,
so I got to talk about them.
That was great.
Thank you for the opportunity.
Now leave office and just please don't
do anything when you're an office is the
Best thing.
But no,
in electoral politics there's no one
because they are part of the machine or
at least they want to be part of the
machine.
So being part of the machine means
making yourself a cog right?
Uninteresting,
uninteresting to me.
Um,
there are very few cultural radicals
left.
There are a few sort of sex radicals.
There's like three,
you know,
I find them interesting,
people who say,
yeah,
we should talk about sex.
We should be able to express our desires
openly.
Uh,
it's better.
Sex is a good thing.
Sex is noT about a,
they almost don't exist.
The sixties had that,
the new left and the counterculture had
some people there who were quite
interesting in that way,
but they're gone and it's very sad.
Yeah,
it's inteResting.
There's this writer,
I forget what he writes for even,
but I don't know if you saw this thing
where he took a screen capture of his
screen and one of these tabs had hentai
porn on it,
which I guess is like octopus
foreigners,
I don't know,
some like some cartoon porn at,
but he's a lefty,
so all these people on this.
All right.
You know,
these,
anything goes over here.
They were all attacking him and I was
like,
do you guys not see the irony in what
you're doing here?
like it wasn't illegal what he was
doing.
It was some odd thing,
you know,
but I though you guys are the free
being,
you know.
All righty.
I mean,
a lot of the left I would imagine It
would attack him too.
I mean they have in the past,
right?
Because that's,
you know,
that's the objectification of women.
So we can't have that.
Um,
yeah,
no,
it's,
it's not fun.
Um,
but.
So in terms of.
Yeah,
no,
I guess I,
I guess it's sort of my mission to kind
of bring back that kind of.
and it is left wing.
here's,
here's part of my politics too,
it's like that sort of left cultural
radicalism back into political
discourse,
which is just doesn't exist really.
So when you say left cultural radical
radicalism,
you meet,
you actually do mean freedom In that
context.
it doesn't sound like something that's
of the modern left now,
but that's what you're.
You're talkIng about real great art or
you're talking about great comedy,
all of those things.
Yeah.
I'm talking about lenny bruce and
richard pryor.
You talked about standup comics.
Those are my heroes.
Those are my original heroes.
Richard pryor is my original hero
because he did that.
He just said,
he said,
well,
you're not supposed to say.
He said what?
You're not supposed to say.
That's what great comedy is.
That's what makes us laugh and that's
what makes them so brilliant.
You know?
And yeah.
I don't know if that's lost,
but it's certainly being challenged.
Oh,
It's being.
It's just being squeezed.
Lenny bruce went to prison for that.
Okay,
and so do we want to return to that?
Do we want to put comedians in jail for
saying things you're not supposed to
say?
Not doing things you're not supposed to
do,
sayIng things you're not supposed to
think.
Giving voice to the taboo,
giving voice to the forbidden.
That's what they do.
Shouldn't we have that?
Imagine what would be happening if
george carlin who would be 80 years old
right now,
we still trying to go to college
campuses.
They'd be screaming about this old white
man who's saying all of these things.
This is a massive problem.
That's why,
by the way,
I was so dispirited,
I guess by bill maher's apology because
everyone knows he's not racist,
so I'm not saying that I'm going to sit
here and want to use that word if it
bothers people.
Of course speech has consequences.
I understand that,
but the apology struck me as man,
a comedian who's been the hero of the
left,
has to now bow to them.
This strikes me as a major problem.
Okay,
you ready to get into more trouble dive?
Let's go.
Okay,
so nigger is arguably the most important
word in american history.
If we don't use that word,
we're not serious about understanding.
American history were not serious,
but understandIng that this culture,
you can be an antiracist or a racist or
anything,
but if you don't talk about that word
and he used that word the way it's been
used in history,
not to hurt people,
not as an epithet,
but to simply refer to it.
Right?
We can't do that.
We're not grownups here.
We're not being serious about ideas,
about history,
about our culture,
about America.
We can't understand it,
and that's really what it is.
It's avoiding these ideas rather than
hitting them head on.
People talk about slavery as if they
know anything.
They don't know anything about slavery.
They just know that it was wrong and
there was whipping his all day long and
it was nothing but rape and torture.
Having never read a thing about the
history of slavery.
It's the same thing,
right?
It's.
It's when you moralize write about ideas
that is anti intellectual,
that is saying,
oh,
this thing is outside the realm of
discourse.
This is outside the realm of inquiry.
It's anti intellectual and it's lazy and
I would say it leads to things that are
worse.
It leads to things like Donald Trump
because you are repressing again these
ideas and there are people who just
won't be repressed and they're going to
come back and they're going to say,
yeah,
you're playing identity politics.
You're saying there's blackness and
whiteness and you're black and I'm
white.
Well,
okay,
fine.
Now I'm going to say I'm about whiteness
and being white.
So that's the problem there.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's a very bad thing to avoid that we
have to use these words.
Yeah.
It's so interesting because I've heard
people make that argument.
I saw my friend michael shermer make
that argument about that you're just
creating an identity politics of white
people.
And I saw him get into a fight with,
with some leftist professor on twitter.
And I,
by the way,
I,
I offered her an opportunity to come
here and defend her ideas.
She declined.
Um,
but I,
I so obviously see that,
but it also leads to all sorts of other
cultural rot because by taking the word
out of huck finn,
well now you.
Well,
that was a book that's it's not only
stood the test of time,
but now you're altering the original
meaning.
Not to mention that huck finn was
antiracist at book,
which as bill maher has been anti,
but the point needs to be made that if
it were racist,
we still have to use the word not as an
epithet.
Again,
not the way the racist used the word,
but we have to be able to talk about
racism.
We're not.
Here's the.
Here's the terrible irony is that by not
being allowed to use that word,
we are not allowed to talk about racism.
We're not allowed to study it.
Think about it.
Take it seriously.
Right.
It's like in Germany,
you're not allowed to basically talk
about nazi-ism unless you just sorta
moralize it really quickly.
Wouldn't you rather as a jew or an anti
nazi or any.
Once you rather a study it really hard
really closely and if you don't want to
return to that,
well,
it's why.
I mean as a free speech guy,
it's why I'm completely against the laws
that criminalize holocaust denial
because they're.
They're not going to stop denying it,
they're just going to go into their
secret little places and I'd rather
have.
There are more real nazis in Germany
than in than in the United States where
we are allowed to talk about it.
Yeah.
But okay,
so you just,
so you said the word now I know a
certain amount of people can be angry
because I have not said the word a
while.
Sitting here with you right this second.
You know that there's a certain costs
there.
You know what I mean,
like,
yeah.
And it just has.
You've just sort of shifted past that.
You've hit your,
you,
you've made your sorta philosophical
point now it's just.
Yeah.
And so just I would just say,
just listened to what I say after the
word because I very clearly put forward
why we should use that word and I'm
pretty sure what I said was anti racist.
Yes.
Anti racist.
That antiracism requires using the word
nigger.
And that's why all this has been
flipped.
So then at evergreen state,
to bring this back to 40 minutes ago at
evergreen state,
you have a professor,
bret weinstein,
who was being anti racist and now he is
smeared,
racist.
So I guess that's what it is when you
don't deal with the truth,
honestly,
you end up having to destroy anyone who
even gets close to it.
Yeah,
yeah.
Uh,
Evergreen is,
I'm not a good luck.
I would say,
uh,
you know,
it's,
I dunno if you want to go into this too
much,
but you know,
a lot of,
there's a lot that's not said about what
causes this craziness on campuses,
which is that,
you know,
there's a monopoly that no one talks
about it.
No one's even aware of this.
In fact,
I wasn't even aware of it until
recently.
The,
the department of education and the
federal government authorizes
accreditation agencies,
accredited colleges and universities,
and they have all these rules.
It's not,
you can't just become a college.
You have to have all these things in
place for them to accredit you.
Without accreditation.
The world doesn't take you seriously.
Employers don't take you seriously,
right?
The credentialing is crucial to this.
Okay?
It's the federal government at the head
of this whole thing of this monopoly
that they have.
Right?
Then on top of that,
there's another monopoly within it,
which is tenure,
the tenure system,
right?
So after seven years,
if you're lucky and you're good and you
follow the rules and you say the right
things,
you get tenure and you're there forever.
Now who do you think you're going to
hire once you have tenure?
Someone who is who is contrary to your
ideas or someone who might agree with
you,
someone who makes you look good or
someone who challenges you.
Hence we have this uniformity of opinion
in academia,
which is supported,
defended,
bolstered by this federal government,
state and force monopoly.
No one knows this.
That's what's going on here.
Third thing,
last thing you add to this,
this system of affirmative action,
okay,
which brings people onto campus who
according to the rules of affirmative
action,
have less training in academic work than
other kids.
So when they get there,
of course it's going to be more
difficult for them to do the academic
work.
Also,
it has been stated,
the purpose of diversity and affirmative
action is to have these people represent
their race.
Right.
And so imagine how crazy that would make
you feel in a classroom when you're like
one black kid or one whatever kid or two
black kids out of 30 and everybody knows
why you're there and you're supposed to
represent your race and people are
wondering assuming that you don't have
the credentials that they do.
That would make me crazy too.
And so I almost everything that's been
said in the race discourse on campuses
over the last three years has been to me
fraudulent or hysterical and much of it
has been totalitarian by the way.
But I think there is something at the
bottom of it that's legitimate.
There's a legitimate grievance that
african american students have
oncologists that's not addressed.
The w,
the tools.
They have to talk about this our only
martin luther king and rosa parks and
malcolm x and you know,
bull connor and oppression and slavery.
So that's the.
That's the,
that's the way they talk about it and
that's uh,
that's unfortunate and that's the fault
of their professors.
We need to give them language to be able
to talk about what's really going on,
which is not good.
It's not fun for them.
It's hard.
I absolutely get that.
It could feel oppressive really.
That word is the word I would use if I
were them,
but it's not the oppression they're
talking about.
There is no physical threat to them.
There never has been there,
but they're.
Yeah.
Interesting.
I referenced my interview with jason
whitlock miller,
but he,
he saId something to that effect that
basically the oppression is different
now.
Uh,
and you have to then change tactics you
can't be doing fighting the way that,
say,
a Jesse Jackson or a,
a al sharpton is using the language of
the old thing when there's a whole
different system in play.
Right,
right.
Where you could get more natural allies.
Yeah.
And I'm only talkIng about academia.
Okay.
I'm not talking about being a 19 year
old in ferguson,
Missouri.
ThAt's a different ballgame entirely.
I'm talking about academia and I know
that world very well.
Those are the rules of the world and
that's what happens to these black kids
there plucked out of these
neighborhoods,
put in these classrooms and said,
oh,
go ahead represent your race.
We're goIng to pay you to do that.
Well,
that's going to make you crazy.
So that's a different.
It's what I call liberal or racial
liberalism.
It's this idea of the representative
race and the idea that we will give them
the chance to prove themselves that they
can be just like us.
So there's an assimilationist impulse in
there too,
or an assimilation is the expectation.
We're going to show the world that these
black people can be just like us,
which by the way is kind of white
supremacist in a way,
right?
Because they're sayiNg,
well,
our world of course is the Best one.
HArvard of course,
is the best place to be.
That's incredibly elitist and superior
and probably white supremacists because
harvard of course is historically a very
white institution,
so just let people do what they want to
do.
We don't have to expect them to go to
harvard.
Well,
I suspect we're going to do this again,
but I want to ask you one final thing
and I think it's sort of been a through
line to what you're talking about.
I sent sort of like an alternate,
so there's sort of a world weariness to
you and then also like a total sense of
opportunity.
Do you think these things are in like 50
slash 50 with you?
Because I have a lot of that too.
I am definitely world.
We,
I worry about the state of the world,
what is going to haPpen to the western
world and society and all these trends
that I talked about that I think are so
dangerous and yet I could never do this
if I didn't have optimism and care about
the ideas.
So I sensed that constantly embattled
how,
where are your percentages?
Where do you get all that to get out of
bed and do what you do?
So,
uh,
people are wealthier than ever before.
There iS less poverty in the world than
ever before.
And so I'm very optimistic about that
going forward.
I constantly worry about war.
I do.
I mean,
you know,
world war two was not that long ago.
Vietnam wasn't that long ago.
Millions of people died in that war that
could happen literally at any minute,
you know,
thinking about the middle east and these
new coalitions that are forming right
now and we have the saudi,
the sunni side with the saudis and the
us and Israel against the shia side with
Iran and Syria and Russia.
And if Turkey makes his decision to go
with the,
with the shia,
which it very well might because of the
kurds.
Then look what we have there.
We have two huge military alliances
potentially fighting each other.
That's terrifying to me.
So I'm always worried about war.
I always will be so long as there are
militaries and there probably will be,
but so I'm split.
I don't know what to say.
You know what?
I'm okay with anything a show on.
I don't know if I can say that's the
difference between this show and most
other shows as long as your organic way.
Very okay.
Alright.
Very good.
Well,
for more of that,
he has checked him out on the twitter,
although he's not on the twitter that
much,
but he'll Jump on for you.
It's at patty,
it's russell and thanks for watching.
We'll do it again next week.